imaginons ce projette le 21 novembre
prochain la Coupe du monde de football
va commencer au Qatar et le rêve de
Vincent Lindon se réalise écoutez la
Coupe du Monde au Qatar Esso sportif de
porter le poids d'une décision politique
ne faut-il pas au contraire profiter de
l'événement au monde au vision pour
faire passer les messages on en débat
dans une minute mais d'abord les
arguments des pros et Antibes avec
Jonathan des priez
à grand renfort de feu d'artifice voilà
le stade de l'usaï lancé en grande pompe
l'enceinte flambant neuve de 80 000
places accueillera la finale de la Coupe
du Monde au Qatar dans deux mois mais
l'événement sportif le plus attendu de
la planète n'en finit plus de faire
polémique au cœur des critiques d'abord
son impact environnemental jugé
désastreux par les ONG les experts si
les organisateurs promettent la
neutralité carbone la compétition se
déroulera dans des stades climatisés
dans l'un des déserts les plus chauds du
monde depuis des mois les appels au
boycott se sont multipliés y compris en
France mais le gouvernement a tranché
vous avez des équipes qui se préparent
depuis des années cette décision elle a
été prise dans un autre contexte
climatique il est possible qu'on
n'aurait pas pris la même c'est pas une
décision qui relève de l'État français
je ne crois pas que le fait de boycotter
la Coupe du monde change malheureusement
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre de
cet événement je préfère regarder devant
moi d'autre part le Qatar a été étriers
pour le concrètement des migrants
employés pour construire les 7 stades et
autres infrastructures de la compétition
selon le gardien 6500 ouvriers
principalement indiens et népalais
aurait perdu la vie sur ses chantiers
révoltant pour certains responsables
écologistes ça me dégoûte en fait je
vous dis allez voir des gens jouer au
foot faire la fête et en dessous il y a
6000 cadavres de de nouveaux Français on
se rend compte de ce que ça fait 6500
personnes qui sont morts pour construire
des stats climatisés mais on est dans
quel monde en fait ça me donne plus
envie c'est pas c'est pas un appel
politique à boycotter les gens ils ont
la télé ils font ce qu'ils veulent je
sais pas mais moi j'ai pas envie en
réponse à ces critiques le Qatar affirme
avoir entrepris des réformes majeures du
marché du travail et tient depuis ce
lundi un forum sur les droits humains le
premier de l'histoire du pays
on débat donc autour de cet appel au
boycott de la Coupe du Monde au Qatar
avec vicage de rassaut bonsoir Vikash
bienvenue vous êtes footballeur ancien
international français finaliste de la
Coupe du monde 2006 et consultant pour
l'équipe et Canal+ Afrique Lola
schulmane bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi
chargé de plaidoyer Amnesty France
Joachim Barbier bonsoir bien reporter au
magazine Society Society Society on peut
dire ça comme ça et SoFoot et puis
Laetitia cruppa qui est resté évidemment
à mes côtés
savoir si vous êtes trop ou antiboycotes
vicash de rasso est-ce que l'équipe de
France doit aller au Qatar
directement
oui je pense que oui enfin en tout cas
moi j'appelle pas boycott en tant que
sportif moi le footballer et je demande
pas aujourd'hui de foot de le faire
après la position de la FFS ça pourrait
être différent et pourrait appeler à
quelque chose et puis l'État français
aussi mais en tout cas en tant que
joueur de foot je demande pas
aujourd'hui de foot de ce positionner le
la Schumann Amnesty International
n'appelle pas au boycott on considère
que cet événement est l'occasion de
mettre la lumière en fait sur ces
situations de violation de droit et
jusqu'au bout donc là dans les deux mois
qui restent on continue de faire
pression pour que les choses changent
pour les travailleurs sur place et faire
pression près de la FIFA auprès de la
FFF et que les joueurs de l'équipe de
France aussi prennent position profiter
de l'événement en quelque sorte
exactement mettre la lumière
on est tous d'accord
non c'est vrai que c'est pas aux joueurs
à le faire parce que voilà le joueur ils
ont leur carrière à gérer qu'une Coupe
du Monde qui je peux en parler c'est
quand même quelque chose mais c'est vrai
que les instances il à faire quelque
chose de symbolique voilà et que on paye
un petit peu
on va dire une logique mercantile de la
FIFA qui aurait dû être l'instance qui
aurait dû contrôler les chantiers bien
sûr cette situation on y reviendra en
détail en détail mais est-ce que vous
pensez vraiment qu'un déjà ça avec vous
joins Kim Barbier que cet événement peut
faire progresser le Qatar ils ont déjà
progressé
il y a trois quatre ans ils avaient mis
en place un bureau de l'Organisation
internationale du travail pour les
accompagner
je sais pas si la fin de de ce qu'on
appelait calafal donc l'espèce de
partenariat là obligé pour
pour les employés pour les salariés mais
il y a il y a quand même une
modernisation on est sur une phase de
modernisation c'est le le second royaume
où habite après l'Arabie Saoudite ils
ont quand même sur tout ce qui est
sociétal et droits des femmes et tout av
en 20 ans beaucoup plus que leurs
voisins est-ce que vous êtes aussi
optimiste il y a eu des avancées sur le
papier c'est-à-dire que Amnesty a
toujours salué quand on a eu la
ratification de PACS internationaux des
Nations Unies quand il y a eu
différentes législations qui ont été
mises en œuvre par le Qatar la signature
de la Corée l'Organisation
internationale du Travail
malheureusement ce qu'on voit c'est que
dans les faits c'est législation et ses
évolutions ne sont pas en oeuvre et on a
encore des travailleurs qui sont en
proie du travail forcé enfin des
personnes qui travaillent 84 heures par
semaine qui n'ont pas eu de jours de
congés quelquefois depuis des mois voire
des années et qui sont vraiment dans un
cycle d'exploitation véritable en fait
et donc aujourd'hui on dénonce cette
situation qui perdure pour nom de
travailleurs migrants dans le pays alors
on a entendu Vincent Lindon on leur
entendra dans un cours instant les items
si vous vous posez la question de du de
l'efficacité on va dire du boycot toutes
ces appels au boycott de politique ou de
personnalité oui des people surtout
alors si l'efficacité c'est pour
empêcher le Mondial bon bah mon édito
est fini parce que c'est non donc est-ce
que il y a une efficacité peut-être pour
alerter l'opinion publique pour
peut-être éveiller les consciences mais
là je pose vraiment la question par
exemple Thomas à la suite de cet appel
de Vincent Lindon les fans de foot comme
lui est-ce que ils vont étendre leur
télévision est-ce qu'il va y avoir des
manifestations dans la rue ou est-ce que
des footballeurs comme vous par exemple
vont décider eux aussi de boycotter on
va réentendre Vincent là non c'était
dans c'est à VOUS bonjour artistique qui
nous explique un petit peu mais bon pour
le moment je ne crois pas alors je suis
pas une spécialiste je crois qu'aucun
joueur n'a déclaré forfait ou n'a
déclaré en tout cas sa position de
boycotter du Mondial mais quand même il
y a certaines voix dans le monde full
balistique qui sont beaucoup plus
légitimes qu'un acteur Vincent l'un dans
la reconnu d'ailleurs comme Eric Cantona
qui se font entendre Eric Cantona
c'était dans une interview daily mails
donc journal britannique en janvier
dernier il a été très clair il a déclaré
c'est seulement une question d'argent ce
n'est qu'une question d'argent et la
façon dont ils ont traité les gens qui
ont construit des stades et horrible et
des milliers de personnes sont mortes et
pourtant nous allons fêter cette coupe
du monde un peu précoce puisque c'était
il y a 9 mois donc cette personne ne la
suivie Éric Cantona dans cette interview
Ermont aussi depuis ce week-end en fait
pour tout vous dire ce matin je l'ai vu
sur un réseau social et d'autres
personnes on veut c'est interviews nous
avons pensé que c'était une prise de
parole qui nous fait une prise de parole
de quelques jours parce que il y a
certainement un mouvement anti cathares
qui monte et qui font monter sur les
réseaux sociaux des arguments ou des
prises de position comme celles d'Éric
Cantona qui date donc de janvier et qui
tourne de plus en plus pour dire non à
ce mondial alors après est-ce que quand
on a eu la bonne carte là encore petit
doute parce que je ne sais pas si vous
rappelez de sa vidéo pour appeler à
vider toutes les banques en 2010 pour
faire s'écrouler le système il appelait
à la révolution à l'époque il y avait
même Christine Lagarde et François
Baroin qui avait réagi personne ou
presque n'avait vidé son fondement alors
Vikash dhoraso vous avez un peu répondu
à la question mais
quand imaginons dans les mois qui
précèdent la Coupe du monde 2006 vous
êtes confronté vous joueur à un débat
comme celui-là
pas une seconde vous dites je vais je
vais pas y aller soyons non non pas une
seconde alors moi je trouve super
l'indignation de Vincent Landon ou de
Cantona après j'aime pas qu'on compare
les footballeurs aux artistes voilà nous
on n'est pas des on chante pas une fois
on fait pas un film une fois on a une
coupe du monde tous les quatre ans quoi
dire c'est tellement rare j'imagine le
Sénégal aujourd'hui qui va jouer la
Coupe du Monde qui est pas qualifié
depuis des années et des années on leur
dit il faut boycotter la Coupe du monde
parce qu'il y a le Qatar il y a des il y
a des problèmes sociétaux sociaux
écologiques aussi c'est compliqué et moi
je suis pas formé avoir une exemplarité
non plus et c'est souvent on peut
trouver ça
non moi je suis formé pour jouer au
football après je peux avoir une
conscience politique une conscience du
monde dans lequel je vis je peux me
battre aussi j'aurais aimé être
aujourd'hui enfin aimer je n'aurais pas
aimé j'aurais aimé avoir le courage face
à cette Coupe du Monde au Qatar de dire
non j'y vais pas mais ce que je l'aurais
fait j'ai joué pour Berlusconi alors que
je défendais les travailleurs voilà on
est on est plein de contradictions Ada
gerberg a quand même refusé jouer une
des meilleures meilleurs jeux du monde
qui a été Ballon d'Or premier ballon
d'or du foot féminin a refusé de jouer
pour la Norvège parce qu'elle était pour
l'égalité salariale et aujourd'hui elle
revient parce qu'ils ont ils ont mis
l'égalité salariale dans son pays allez
courageuse moi je suis très honnête
comme comme fan de football je me suis
posé la question mais ma réponse a été
assez rapide je vais la regarder cette
cette coupe du monde voilà que que les
choses soient soit soit clair je vois
qu'il Barbier un joueur qui renonce un
mondial pour des raisons politiques
alors moi je croyais qu'il y avait un
précédent c'était Yoann Crush la légende
du football néerlandais en 1978 la Coupe
du Monde 78 ça se passe en Argentine
c'est la dictature de Georges
espagnol Videla et en fait on a on a su
après que c'était plus compliqué que ça
c'est plus compliqué que ça il y avait
des problèmes avec la Fédération et puis
donc voilà mais toujours est-il une
agression aussi quelques quelques
semaines auparavant il avait été pris en
otage avec sa famille donc voilà et donc
tout ça fait que le meilleur joueur du
monde de l'époque avait pas participé à
à la Coupe du monde donc en Argentine
918 à l'époque était une pure dictature
les jouets des horreurs qui se passaient
à quelques mètres
du stade et c'est marrant parce qu'il y
avait eu un début de débat comme ça en
France sauf que la France n'avait pas
joué une coupe de monde depuis 12 ans
plus depuis 1966 et tout le monde
attendait cette coupe du monde et je
crois qu'il y avait Dominique Rocheteau
qui après coup avait un petit peu
exprimé ça ça gêne mais
la question de l'exemplarité de la la
France politique des joueurs de foot
effectivement ils ont souvent bandeau en
demande une exemplarité que les hommes
politiques sur lesquels ils
s'affranchissent assez facilement en
temps des discours il faut parler à tout
le monde voilà le joueur de foot il est
là pour jouer au foot c'est ce qu'on lui
a appris depuis ses 15 ans et donc voilà
alors vous serez peut-être pas d'accord
puisque le la chômeur Amnesty a publié
au printemps dernier une lettre ouverte
au bleu donc c'est alors conscience
politique ou alors engagement politique
finalement vous adressiez qu'est-ce que
vous demandiez précisément alors déjà on
s'est adressé aux gens de l'équipe de
foot parce qu'on n'avait pas eu de
réponse du côté de la Fédération
Française de Football donc c'est aussi
on avait tenté d'engager un dialogue on
avait rencontré en avril dernier la
Fédération Française de Football et on
avait demandé au président à Noël le
Great de prendre la parole publiquement
pour dire que
il y avait encore des violations des
droits en tout cas qui avaient un long
chemin encore à parcourir pour le Qatar
pour respecter les droits des
travailleurs et face au refus de la FFF
on sait aussi tourner vers les joueurs
de l'équipe de France pour leur dire
voilà du fait de votre responsabilité de
votre aura
auprès de l'opinion auprès des jeunes il
est important de montrer votre
solidarité parce que c'est bien grâce au
travailleur migrants à toutes les
personnes que vous allez être
accueillies et bien accueillis au Qatar
que vous allez avoir des superbes stades
que vous allez être accueillis dans
votre hôtel que des personnes vont faire
le ménage dans votre chambre vous vous
accompagner du stade à l'hôtel à
l'entraînement et donc c'est aussi un
message de solidarité vis-à-vis des
travailleurs et dont on souhaitait que
des joueurs d'équipe de France
s'engagent et prennent la parole à ce
sujet et on a eu aucune réponse de la
part des gens il y a eu une réponse
ultra un peu langue de bois un peu
encore le moins faible de Didier
sélectionneur national quelques jours
après la publication de cette lettre
ouverte en écoute sélectionnant
c'est un sujet sensible très sensible la
Fédération Française je me permets je
suis pas président mais j'échange
beaucoup avec mon président a fait les
démarches nécessaires comme toutes les
nations pour faire en sorte d'être bien
vigilant attentif à cette situation
là-bas
après vous avoir dit ça je vais pas
j'ai pas envie de rentrer dans un débat
médiatique
ça c'est clair ce qui n'empêche que
chaque individu chaque personne a et
aura sa liberté d'expression alors il y
a un peu de langue de bois mais en même
temps il y a des informations donc il
répond à la lettre dont vous parlez donc
c'est vraiment sur le sort des ouvriers
sur de ça de ces ouvriers étrangers
quand il dit la Fédération a fait des
démarches nécessaires pour faire en
sorte d'être attentif à la situation
là-bas à quoi fait-il référence alors je
pense qu'il fait référence à la question
qu'on avait abordé pour notre
rendez-vous avec la FFF en avril on
avait demandé à la FFF d'engager son
devoir de vigilance et de s'assurer
auprès de l'hôtel notamment qu'ils
avaient choisi qu'il n'y a aucune
violation des droits qui soit commise
par vis-à-vis de travailleur au sein de
l'hôtel et donc mais qui rendent public
parce que toute cette démarche doit être
transparente et de nombreuses
fédérations fait le choix de la
transparence on a la Fédération Suisse
qui a fait un questionnaire à l'ensemble
des hôtels pour leur dire qu'en est-il
du respect des droits et ensuite ils ont
décidé bon bah voilà on a décidé de
choisir telle hôtel parce qu'on sait que
les droits seront respectés dans
au sein de l'hôtel qu'on a choisi on n'a
pas eu du tout cette démarche
transparente de la part de la FFS ce qui
est bien regrettable parce que justement
c'est en faisant cette démarche publique
qu'on obtient aussi des changements de
la part du gouvernement du Qatar
finalement les joueurs ils se retrouvent
en première ligne parce que la CD a pas
tout à fait son travail ou à pas le
courage de s'engager est-ce que vous
diriez ça je dirais plutôt qu'ils sont
en première ligne parce que la FIFA a
décidé contribuer la Coupe du Monde
comment voilà et c'est à ce moment-là
peut-être que de toute façon très
collective les joueurs mais notamment
les fédérations ou les pays pouvaient
dire non on n'ira pas au kata après ça
devient bien plus compliqué et oui être
vigilant déjà moi je trouve qu'être
informé être sensibilisé et bien
conscient de ce qui se passe là-bas et
voilà on va un endroit il se passe ça on
est conscient on va essayer de nous être
exemplaire dans cette situation là c'est
déjà pas mal donc là quand vous dites
nous vous mettez à la place je serai
toujours défendrai toujours parce qu'on
est on est facilement attaqué je je sais
que tous les footballeurs font beaucoup
de choses au niveau social dans leur
quartier dans leur club d'origine
parfois dans leur pays d'origine pour
redonner et on vient tous de quartier
populaire on est souvent ici
l'immigration et on n'oublie pas d'où on
vient j'espère vous êtes commentateur
est-ce que en tant que commentateur vous
allez aussi commenter cette situation là
est-ce que vous allez prendre parti
est-ce que vous allez servir à éveiller
les consciences de voter les spectateurs
aussi librement vous allez commenter
cette
parole libre le but c'est de défendre
les footballeurs mais aussi de parler
des petits problèmes politiques sociaux
qui peuvent prendre la parole justement
vis-à-vis de l'équipe de France on avait
fait la demande de rencontrer l'équipe
de France justement pour la sensibiliser
et échanger avec les joies pour leur
dire voilà la situation de droits
humains et on est dans le pardon on est
dans le soft power qu'on est dans le
dans l'influence puisque toute cette
Coupe du Monde il y a des on va en
parler dans un instant à Quentin c'est
il y a des enjeux d'image qui sont
gigantesques pour le Qatar donc c'est
surtout en fait d'autres fédérations ont
fait ce jeu-là et donc il y a des
sections d'amnistie notamment en
Belgique ils ont eu une session
d'information avec l'équipe belge pour
leur parler de cette question de
situation de droits humains et donc
cette information est nécessaire pour
sensibiliser et pour savoir quelle est
la situation sur place et aussi quelle
est leur marge de manoeuvre et qu'est-ce
qu'ils peuvent prendre comme position
alors il y a un autre aspect de la
déclaration de Didier champ que je
trouve quand même intéressant quand il
dit chaque individu chaque personne aura
sa liberté d'expression Joachim Barbier
sauf que si je ne me trompe vous avez
peut-être dire le contraire mais le
règlement de la FIFA interdit aux
joueurs de prendre des positions
politiques à l'occasion d'un match
comment ça se passe on peut pas par
exemple retirer son maillot et avant en
dessous un t-shirt avec un message
politique donc est-ce que cette liberté
de parole on peut imaginer qu'elle
s'exprime effectivement au Qatar pendant
la Coupe du Monde oui mais elle
s'exprimera ailleurs effectivement c'est
assez cadré c'est même très cadré de
façon assez hypocrite sur sur le autour
des stades et sur le terrain je pense
que effectivement d'une part les joueurs
vont être sur place donc ils vont être
confrontés une réalité même si
effectivement ils sont dans une ils sont
dans une bulle mais rien ne les
empêchera de d'aller voir de discuter et
après ça passera par les réseaux sociaux
obligatoirement donc vous pensez que
certains se saisiront saisiront
l'occasion peut-être peut-être j'ai pas
j'ai pas d'assurance c'est chaque
joueur à sa propre conscience c'est
souvent une cause ou un sujet qui défend
par exemple enfin comme le disait vicash
Sadio Mané joueur sénégalais de
Liverpool maintenant Bayern de Munich il
dépense enfin il y a une partie de son
salaire énorme qui réinvestit dans des
dans des dans des écoles et tout donc
parce que parce que ça le touche
particulièrement donc voilà après quels
sont les joueurs je ne sais pas qui vont
se qui vont éventuellement s'impliquer
mais il y en aura sûrement mais
d'ailleurs il casseurs ça rejoint la
question que vous posez Laetitia tout à
l'heure en tant que commentateur est-ce
que c'est pendant qu'on commente un
match de la Coupe du monde qu'il faut
faire passer le message sur les droits
sociaux des travailleurs étrangers ou
alors est-ce que c'est maintenant est-ce
que c'est maintenant que les joueurs de
l'équipe de France peuvent se saisir du
dossier les joueurs c'est difficile pour
eux faut vraiment
scrutés on a vu Mbappé l'autre fois qui
a un peu dérapé hop ça donne une c'est
difficile Mbappé la 22 ans voilà après
Galtier aurait pu être sur lui avait une
responsabilité en tant que entraîneur
MP3
il a pris position très fortement quand
tu es discriminations les inégalités
c'est un joueur anglais de 22 ans qui
jouent à Manchester qui a forcé le
Premier ministre à continuer à prolonger
les aides au plus démunis au plus
fragile en Angleterre voilà on a de la
force moi je je je
me bats c'est Maradona qui le faisait
c'est pour ça que vous l'avez sur
évidemment non mais la FIFA c'est une
instance particulière ultra puissante et
les joueurs de foot ont du poids ou de
la force si ce
rassemble ils peuvent reprendre le
pouvoir reprendre le lit ils peuvent
décider de plein plein plein de choses
et reprendre le pouvoir sur la FIFA
aussi parce que s'ils arrêtent de jouer
il y a peu il y a pas de football
matraque les joueurs de foot d'ailleurs
le enfin le le poids le pouvoir qu'on
donne aux arbitres aujourd'hui c'est
pour affaiblir les joueurs de foot c'est
juste oui
c'est pas notre débat mais bon vous
l'avez dit donc on pour l'évoquer
prendre la parole maintenant informée
sur les libertés au Qatar et je propose
à Quentin calmerde de nous rejoindre on
voit bien que c'est d'autant plus
important rebonsoir Quentin qui a
énormément
d'enjeux ça dépasse de très loin cette
Coupe du Monde au Qatar l'aspect sportif
exactement et ce sont même les
responsables politiques et catharriques
qui le disent eux-mêmes on a eu cette
tribune publiée en décembre 2010 une
semaine après la décision effectivement
de décerner au Qatar cette organisation
cette Coupe du Monde on a vu cette
tribune de l'ambassadeur au Qatar dans
cet ordre du Qatar en France qui avait
commenté la décision de la FIFA regardez
cette citation il avait dit pour la
région les enjeux liés à cette
manifestation ne sont pas simplement
sportifs ni même économique ils sont
aussi et surtout politiques et sociaux
politiques et car cette victoire peut
changer la donne au Moyen-Orient le
Mondial de football et l'un des reins
événements susceptibles de renforcer à
la fois la solidarité entre les pays de
la région et la qualité du dialogue
entre les civilisations moins de moins
en outre donner le sentiment aux jeunes
arabes qui ne sont pas mis au banc des
nations et d'une importance capitale
écrivait-il et l'ambassadeur à l'époque
de remercier particulièrement la France
qui avait soutenue la candidature du
Qatar et donc on est en 2010 cette
décision elle fait suite à d'autres
décisions peut-être un peu similaires de
la FIFA exactement Thomas on parle à
l'époque de stratégie d'ouverture vers
de nouvelles contrées pour le football
mondial c'est ce que j'ai lu dans les
articles de l'époque de la part de cette
Blatter lui-même décrit comme le chantre
de la mondialisation du football du
ballon vous le voyez à l'image ici de
ces images d'ailleurs qui date de
l'époque et dans les articles
effectivement de 2010 on pointe aussi
déjà les soupçons de corruption dans
l'instant du foot effectivement après le
Japon la Corée du Sud en 2002 l'Afrique
du Sud en 2010 la FIFA octroi le tournoi
la Russie pour 2018 ce jour-là et au
Qatar donc en 2022 donc le même jour ils
annoncent Russie et kata forcément il y
a des soupçons que de corruption le
Qatar alors là on va remonter encore un
peu plus loin dans le qui m'est je
parlais de soft power des cas une vraie
stratégie en la matière ça ça date des
années 90 exactement l'idée c'est
d'acquérir une place sur l'échiquier
internationale c'est un tout petit pays
en investissant dans des clubs à
l'étranger ou dans des événements vous
voyez ces images bien sûr du PSG là
c'est un entraînement de l'équipe du PSG
qui avait été qui avait été délocalisé à
Doha au Qatar en 2015 mais on pense
aussi à Kataria Waze qui a été le
partenaire du Tour de France dans les
années 2010 ou même et bien le Prix de
l'Arc de Triumph qui a été renommée vous
voyez cathare pris de l'Arc de Triomphe
le Qatar qui s'affiche partout sur
toutes les banderoles de l'événement
lorsque ce prix ce concours a lieu et
donc pour deux chercheurs du CNRS tout
ça c'est que et bien il y a cet effet
effectivement de soft power qui
constitue la diplomatie et que constitue
la diplomatie sportive le Qatar cherche
ainsi à accroître sa notoriété
d'augmenter le courant de sympathie
mondiale à son égard et le Qatar cherche
ainsi à consolider propositions et
géopolitique en divertissant son
économie pour la pérennité de celle-ci
sauf qu'il peut y avoir un effet
boomerang exactement c'est le revers
c'est ce que notre ces chercheurs dans
cette étude que effectivement on a lu il
peut y avoir effectivement un revers
avec les critiques liées au-delà des
critiques liées au bilan carbone de
l'événement c'est et bien qui a un
message qui est comme cela brouillé
selon ses chercheurs parce que on s'en
renvoie l'idée comme ça d'un d'une
puissance de nouveaux riches et en plus
ça l'a fait un effet vitrine qui montre
les Ford inégalités écrivent ces
chercheurs de la répartition de la
richesse dans ces pays cette vitrine
peut alors se transformer en cadeau
empoisonné pour le Qatar merci beaucoup
Quentin pour tout
ces détails bon on parle de propagande
en fait
je reviens au cœur de votre mobilisation
le sort de ces de ces ouvriers étrangers
qui ont construit ces stades stades
réfrigérés ou climatisé je sais pas quel
est le bon terme on y pas sur le bilan
carbone de cette coupe du monde parce
que là aussi on est dans on est dans
l'aberration mais il y a ce chiffre
6500 morts c'est le quotidien
britannique de Guardian qui donnait ce
chiffre en quête qui date d'il y a 18
mois février 2021 donc 18 mois plus tard
quels sont vos chiffres je sais même pas
si c'est possible de répondre à la
question quoi est-ce que vous avez pu
investiguer là-bas alors on a fait des
recherches sur la question des décès des
travailleurs migrants Qatar on est dans
l'incapacité de donner des chiffres et
de corroborer les chiffres du Guardian
on sait que des milliers de personnes
sont mortes directement liées aux
conditions de travail de ces ouvriers il
faut savoir que c'est un travail sous
très forte chaleur quelquefois 40 50
degrés dehors ou voilà on a répertorié
des cas de personnes qui sont décédées
parce que elles avaient travaillées 12
14 heures par jour dans à conduire des
camions il n'y avait pas d'air
conditionné et donc ils sont retrouvés
mortes dans leur lit le lendemain alors
même qu'elle n'avait aucun aussi de
santé c'est-à-dire que aujourd'hui la
situation des travailleurs c'est
évidemment l'absence de transparence
concernant les chiffres des décès et
c'est aussi l'absence d'indemnisation
des travailleurs et des violations des
droits vous le fait que aujourd'hui on
demande à la FIFA de mettre en place un
programme d'indemnisation de réparation
des violations des droits des
travailleurs qui seraient une première
en fait pour un événement sportif d'une
telle ampleur est nécessaire parce que
les familles des personnes de yées n'ont
jamais reçu d'indemnisation puisque le
Qatar n'est pas responsable sur le
papier sur les certificats d'essai écrit
problème respiratoires ou causes non
connu et donc dans ces cas-là les
familles n'ont aucune indemnisation et
pour certaines d'entre elles ont même dû
s'endetter pour faire rapatrier le corps
de leurs proches donc la situation est
terrible pour ces travailleurs et c'est
travailleuses parce qu'il y a aussi de
nombreuses femmes qui ont quitté leur
pays qui sont aujourd'hui travaille au
domestiques qui travaillent dans des
hôtels qui sont même aussi agents de
sécurité et donc leur situation est
extrêmement préc pour nombre d'entre
elles Jacqueline
au Qatar vous avez finalement vu les
efforts qui étaient annoncés par par ce
pays mais moi j'ai l'impression que
c'est un peu un château de cartes de
communication qui est en train de
s'écrouler avec ces chiffres c'est
chaque coupe du monde ou Jeux Olympiques
est toujours une opération de
communication pour un pays que ça soit
un pays démocratique que ça soit un pays
un peu plus
un peu moins démocratique et on a eu une
séquence là assez étrange avec à la fois
la Russie le Qatar la Chine pour les
Jeux Olympiques et à chaque fois les
projecteurs sont braqués et les
organisateurs pensent qu'ils vont
pouvoir vendre leur pays et puis toutes
ces toutes ces merveilles et puis aussi
bah parce que les journalistes s'y font
leur boulot on voit aussi l'envers du
décor mais c'est vrai que sur cette
question
des travailleurs c'est très très
compliqué de savoir ce qui s'est passé
parce que c'est pas la vendre enquête du
Guardian mais avant il y en avait eu
d'autres et petit à petit les chiffres
ont augmenté et les très compliqués
d'aller d'une part dans ces ces parties
du kata ou c'est ou ses ouvriers euh
sont logés et donc voilà et là on est
vraiment sur on il y a plein de choses à
discuter sur sur cette coupe du monde
mais là on est vraiment sur un aspect du
du dossier qui est qui est qui est un
défendable donc voilà c'est c'est parce
que on joue vraiment sur il y aura
toujours des des pauvres gars au fin
fond des montagnes du Népal ou de ou du
Bangladesh pour venir bosser dans pour
construire des stades c'est ça le
c'est-à-dire qu'on est dans un système
qui est complètement officiel et je
finis juste effectivement la FIFA je
pense c'est une responsabilité en ne pas
en n'ayant pas acté sur sur le contrôle
de ces chantiers en sachant très bien
que que la situation existait déjà avant
avant même d'acter sur la situation des
chantiers c'est pourquoi l'afficha
choisi le Qatar vous le disiez tout à
l'heure ça c'est ça mais à la base
pourquoi
on va parler d'argent là
[Musique]
très corrompus très puissant aussi donc
voilà il y a des enjeux qui nous
dépassent et c'est en tout cas pas les
droits sociaux c'est en tout cas pas
l'écologie puisque là pour le coup elle
est au Qatar c'était c'est pas possible
quoi c'est c'est ça moi je suis vraiment
sors d'un cadre du cadre politique il y
a pas d'agence politique possible alors
que là récemment ils ont exclu la Russie
sa première fois de l'histoire de je
pense de la FIFA tu que enfin qu'on
décide de exclure un pays là ils ont
fait la politique maintenant ils vont
être coincé oui parce qu'on pourra leur
demander de faire la même chose de le
faire mais en tout cas ils l'ont fait
en 92 qu'en 2010 et c'est ça qui a aussi
intéressant le moment où maman où on
attribue du Monde 2022 au Qatar il n'y a
aucune contrepartie qui est demandé au
Qatar sur la question des droits humains
la question des droits humains
n'apparaît même pas au moment du deal
qui est signé avec le Qatar alors que la
FIFA pourrait faire de la politesse
pourrait faire de la politique
exactement c'est à qui l'a fallu entre
2010 et aujourd'hui la pression des ONG
quand même l'estime aussi qui ont permis
que ces évolutions législatives dont on
a parlé mais c'est parce qu'on a fait
pression parce qu'on a casser un peu le
bloc de communication du Qatar en disant
tout va très bien maintenant circuler il
y a rien à voir et qu'on a continué à
marteler notre message il y a quand même
un élément qui est assez révélateur je
trouve sur le cynisme en l'occurrence du
président de la Fédération
internationale de football s'appelle
Janine Santino regardez ce qu'il disait
au mois de mai de cette année alors il
se raccroche à son histoire
personnellement ont migré d'Italie en
Suisse quand vous donnez du travail à
quelqu'un même dans des conditions
difficiles vous lui donnez de la dignité
de la fierté ce n'est pas de la charité
la FIFA n'est pas la police du monde ou
responsable pour tout ce qui se se passe
dans le monde je vois Kim Barbier c'est
du enfin répondre ça aux accusations
d'Amnesty internationales ou de Human
Right sur le sur les conditions de
travail des des ouvriers étrangers au
Qatar c'est plus que du cynisme ah c'est
pathétique mais mais il y a un problème
avec les instances du football que ça
soit au niveau de la Fédération
Française de l'UEFA de la FIFA et un tel
décalage entre la société civile le pays
réelle et ces gens-là on voit alors là
c'est un scandale la FFF c'est quand
même pas terrible non plus voilà je
crois que c'est Platini qui disait
pourtant qui faisait partie du truc qui
disait à chaque congrès de la FIFA avant
azuri qui disait tant que les membres du
comité exécutif il y a un chauffeur taxi
pour amener leur femme leur maîtresse
faire du shopping ils sont contents donc
voilà il y a il y a
cette organisation de plus en plus de
compétition pour faire de plus en plus
d'argent pour avoir le plus de plus de
pouvoir et peut-être aussi de plus en
plus de réglementer ce type de marché
est-ce que je veux dire est-ce qu'il y a
pas le pouvoir politique de et ensuite
savoir qu'il est élu à la clamation ses
copains ils arrivent ils applaudissent
et il y avait réélu c'est comme ça que
font cela FIFA moi là il y a eu la Ligue
fermée qui était proposée à un moment
alors là on parle de Coupe d'Europe avec
les clubs les plus puissants au niveau
européen d'autres organismes pour qu'ils
pourraient organiser le football la FIFA
enfin ça appartient pas à la FIFA le
football donc il faudrait se réorganiser
avec des avec des d'autres règles et qui
que solidaires et c'est une sorte de
pouce que vous proposez il y a le
football appartient au footballeur et
tout le monde et pas que à la FIFA
personne ne contrôle la FIFA quel
organisme qui contrôle le FIFA est
tellement puissant
l'action de d'ONG des principes sur la
question des droits humains au sein de
la FIFA ce qui existe maintenant c'est
qu'on a un cadre principe humain mais
qui commencera après le Qatar aussi donc
le Qatar c'est c'est à partir de 2010
c'était finalement plus tard que ces
principes seront en place ce qui est
intéressant c'est dire oui la FIFA a un
rôle essentiel mais la FIFA est gérée
par les fédérations nationales et donc
c'est le rôle des fédérations nationales
de faire pression au sein de la FIFA
pour dire que elle doit mettre en place
des réformes elle doit s'assurer qu'il
n'y a aucune commission de violation des
droits il y avait une assemblée générale
de la FIFA qui s'est déroulée à Doha il
y a quelques mois où il y a eu la
présidente de la Fédération finlandaise
qui a tenu un discours assez incroyable
sur la question des droits humains et
elle était extrêmement courageuse
d'avoir ce discours là la Fédération
Française n'a pas parlé du tout de ces
questions là or c'est essentiel et ils
ont un à jouer au sein de la FIFA au
sein de cet organisme pour dire en fait
nous les droits humains ça compte au
niveau de notre fédération et on veut
que la FIFA soit exemplaire
malheureusement en France la FFF ne
l'est pas et il y a quand même un
argument qui qui pouvait peser et qui a
sans doute pesé dans la décision Joachim
barbier de octroyer la Coupe du Monde de
22 au Qatar c'est ce que disait Quentin
dans son synchronique tout à l'heure ce
que ça représente symboliquement c'était
la première fois que cette partie du
monde organise un mondial organise et ça
peut pas enfin il y a aussi cette idée
alors certes c'est du business dans la
logique de cette Blatter puis Infantino
de toucher le plus de pays possible
c'est du business mais c'est pas
totalement faux de dire que on ne peut
pas éternellement privé cette partie du
monde de l'organisation d'un événement
comme celui-là mais sur la citation de
vous avez montré la dernière phrase je
suis on peut être d'accord il dit pour
que le jeunes arabes ne sont pas à
l'écart voilà mais comme vous le dites
c'est pas le la diffusion du
[Musique]
c'est une aberration écologique on est
tous d'accord pour pour le dire mais
est-ce qu'on pourrait organiser une
coupe du monde dans cette partie de la
planète sans des sans stats climatisés
et donc avec des conditions qui
respectent pas forcément nos ambitions
en termes de bilan carbone vous voyez ce
que je veux dire est-ce que ils ont
déplacer la Coupe du monde pour pouvoir
les jouer les matchs parce que c'est ils
faisaient trop chaud et c'est oui pas
être utilisés avec la climatisation oui
elle est organisée en plein hiver ce qui
d'ailleurs complique les calendriers
donc pour cette raison n'importe quoi
après quoi voilà au niveau écologique
c'est n'importe quoi et après c'est au
niveau des supporters aussi le
l'engouement qui peut y avoir les stades
vont être au même endroit il va rien se
passer parce que c'est un petit pays
donc
oui au niveau écologique il y a un vrai
vrai problème mais ça c'est le départ de
la FIFA on revient alors oui on attribue
pas oui mais je vous repose la question
dans ces cas-là on a on attribue pas non
plus le la Coupe du monde à l'Egypte ou
à l'Algérie et le Maroc qui sont là pour
le coup des pays de la tradition
footballistique et de passion
footballistiques
énormes
à quel quel est la limite pour qu'on
puisse attribuer au niveau des des
bonnes pratiques etc est-ce qu'il fait
qu'on va là et pas là quoi qu'est-ce
qu'elle est la limite moi je sais pas il
répond en tout cas j'ai l'impression que
le cadavre c'est pas génial oui ça on
est tous d'accord pour dire que c'était
peut-être pas le le meilleur choix puis
je reviens on va boucler ce débat sur la
question du du boycott bon on est tous à
peu près d'accord pour dire que c'est
pas forcément au sportif de ne pas y
aller Laetitia je sais pas
je pense que tout être humain sportif
quelle que soit son statut à une
conscience politique
et ensuite la question des responsables
politiques qui va représenter la France
là-bas écouter Scandi l'ancien président
de la République François Hollande
c'était dans l'émission quotidien la
semaine dernière je crois que c'est une
trop grande responsabilité demandée à
des joueurs ici prépare depuis des
années cette coupe du monde donc je
crois pas qu'on puisse leur dire n'y
allez pas et on vous demande de ne pas y
aller en revanche est-ce que les chefs
d'État et de gouvernement sont amenés à
aller dans les stades en question je
crois que ça sera difficile pour eux
d'aller même si c'est même si la
climatisation est assurée une petite
blague François Hollande comme toujours
Lola est-ce que alors c'est plus facile
à dire quand on est plus président de la
République évidemment est-ce que vous
vous militez pour ça qui doit
représenter la France là déjà c'est même
pas tant ce qui va se passer le 20
novembre lors du match du coup dans moi
c'est entre maintenant et le 20 novembre
c'est quelle parole le gouvernement en
français va avoir vis-à-vis de cette
coupe du monde et donc c'est important
de se dire que aujourd'hui il est temps
qu'on ait une prise de parole publique
également du gouvernement français sur
la question des droits humains et dire
que on n'est pas dupe et on sait les
enjeux et on sait ce qui va se passer et
ce qui s'est passé en fait pour
l'organisation de ce Mondial donc en
fait on n'est pas c'est pas tant le
l'histoire du symbolique c'est une
histoire d'action concrète et c'est ça
aujourd'hui qu'on demande c'est des
prises de parole publique concrètes pour
permettre de faire en sorte qu'il y a
qui est une mobilisation et qui est
justement au niveau de l'opinion
publique cette prise de conscience et
donc c'est plus la responsabilité des
hommes politiques et des femmes
politiques aujourd'hui de prendre la
parole de mettre le sujet sur la table
et de dire que la France a un discours
concernant les droits humains au Qatar
et qu'on ne ferme pas les yeux sur les
droits des personnes LGBTI contre ne
ferme pas les yeux sur la question des
droits des femmes dans le pays et
évidemment sur la question des droits
des travailleurs migrants dans le pays
et donc c'est plutôt maintenant qu'on
les attend et pas tant le 20 novembre
qu'est-ce que vous répondait à cette à
cette question parce qu'on aurait pu se
la poser aussi pour les Jeux Olympiques
en Chine ou en Russie par exemple quelle
est la question par la question c'est la
même question c'est est-ce que qui doit
représenter la France est-ce que c'était
Emmanuel Macron est-ce que c'est la
première ministre est-ce que c'est la
ministre des sports ou même un cran en
dessous pardon je sais pas quel est le
protocole je pense que le la France est
représenté par le président de la
fédération qui sera sûrement là-bas
après tout dépendra des des résultats si
la France va loin notamment en finale
comme c'était le cas en Russie on ira et
puis dans les vestiaires on s'appellera
le champagne
c'est un peu le paradoxe du foot c'est
une telle machine à produire des
émotions qu'on est capable de un peu de
mettre en veille une partie de son
cerveau c'est ce qui est à la fois ce
qui ce qui explique pourquoi il y a tout
d'un coup un million de personnes sur
les Champs-Élysées quand on gagne et
puis des fois il y a quand même beaucoup
de il y a beaucoup d'hypocrisie
euh je sais pas je pense que si je pense
que les les responsables politiques
français je pense qu'ils sont un peu
embêtés avec cette question donc voilà
si à ceux qui sont au pouvoir c'est plus
facile position c'est plus facile donc
voilà je enfin c'est pas que j'aimerais
pas être à leur place mais je pense
qu'ils vont
godiller pour essayer de sauver la face
de rassaut vous dites quoi vous dites
service minimum en terme de
représentation nationale là-bas ils sont
piégés ils vont me faire de la politique
et ils vont être obligés d'y aller quoi
oui parce que il y a des enjeux
importants vers le
Qatar aujourd'hui et présent opération
Germain par exemple sur voilà c'est
compliqué c'est et puis d'ailleurs c'est
si j'ai bien compris Nicolas Sarkozy qui
a travaillé pour que ça puisse exister
Michel Platini aussi était en cours ah
c'est c'est un soluce cette histoire je
pense qu'on est piégé et eux alors
évidemment l'opposition va dire aux
politiques en place de prendre position
d'être ferme etc et puis pas se passer
grand chose et surtout qu'ils ont du gaz
à nous de nous fournir en ce moment donc
c'est peut-être pas le moment de se
fâcher avec le avec le Qatar est-ce que
vous vous êtes un sportif engagé on le
comprend c'est aussi pour ça que vous
êtes vous êtes ici engagé via des
associations est-ce que parfois ça
reprend une question que vous posez
Laetitia tout à l'heure est-ce que vous
dites que ce sport peut dans ces
instants dans dans la façon de de
fonctionner de la gouvernance comme on
dit du football est-ce que vous vous
pensez vraiment que ça peut changer ça
doit changer mais ça va changer je pense
que ce vieux monde est en train de
s'écrouler le Great a eu
une enquête de So Foot aujourd'hui qui
qui dit qu'il avait envoyé des SMS à
caractère sexuel aussi prise de position
sur le racisme sur l'homophobie sur les
femmes récent récentes sont mauvaises et
il est toujours en poste donc voilà ça
ça va changer faut le système de vote
aussi doit changer moi je suis un joueur
de foot la plupart des joueurs de foot
sont
issus des quartiers populaires de
l'immigration on n'est jamais représenté
dans les instances on a le droit de
jouer au football pas le droit de
prendre des positions on peut diriger on
peut être consulté voilà donc ça veut
dire que tout ça doit changer les femmes
doivent être représentées la Fédération
Française de foot c'est 13 personnes au
comité exécutif il y a trois femmes
obligatoires il y en a trois il y en a
pas 4 donc c'est vraiment ça qui doit
changer Joachim Barbier est-ce que vous
êtes aussi optimiste que que sur la
capacité du là en l'occurrence du foot
français a changé le vieux monde va
résister car il Waterloo mais
effectivement il y a un écart de plus en
plus grand et et qui n'a pas de sens
entre les gens qui dirigent le football
et puis et puis les gens qui jouent et
qui le suivent quoi on voit bien sur
enfin qu'il y a une accélération de
l'Histoire et que comme l'a dit
Noël le Great quand il dit il y a pas de
racisme dans le football ce n'est pas
possible de dire ça ne pas être impliqué
dans les questions écologiques ce n'est
pas possible sur la parité ce n'est plus
possible donc il va falloir sûrement
forcer les portes je pense que
effectivement ça passe par la présence
d'anciens joueurs mais aussi un autre
parce que le système complètement
cadenassée si vous voulez vous présenter
à la Fédération française de football il
faut des parrainages c'est très
compliqué donc voilà mais le système
doit
se renouveler ou alors il va exploser
d'un mot vraiment en quelques secondes
vous qui avez été en contact finalement
avec la Fédération est-ce que vous avez
cette impression qu'elle est un peu hors
sol parce que c'est ce que vous venez
d'écrire par rapport à la réalité en
tout cas on se rend bien compte qu'un
problème de tabou sur la question des
droits humains dans le foot en France
comparé à d'autres fédérations et ce qui
se passe dans d'autres pays c'est
complètement enfin il y a un décalage
immense et c'est important de noter ça
certaines spécificité française
aujourd'hui sur la question des droits
humains dans le foot on pourrait suivre
l'exemple d'autres pays beaucoup plus
engagés dans les deux ou trois mois qui
viennent avant le début de cette Coupe
du Monde très vite que l'émission entre
hommes et femmes tous les pays le font
partout dans le monde on va être les
derniers encore une fois bon allez le
message est passé merci beaucoup avec
agent assaut merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce à ce débat je vous donne
rendez-vous demain 18h 22h je rappelle
les les horaires c'est le redémarrage de
la saison pour un nouveau numéro de sens
public et puis l'invité Dorian Mancini
demain 8h c'est Nicolas Dupont-Aignan le
député de l'Essonne président de Debout
la France bonne soirée